aujourd'hui on va s'occuper de
l'échauffement avant la course tout
d'abord si vous commencez votre sortie
d'entraînement tranquillement ça peut
suffire comme échauffement c'est à dire
que ça va permettre naturellement à
votre corps de monter en température et
la de vous sentir bien ensuite si vous
voulez vraiment faire quelques exercices
avant de démarrer tout d'abord vous
pouvez par exemple faire les
traditionnels flexion c'est pas mal
parce que ça va permettre à votre coeur
de monter en rythme c'est intéressant
c'est important pour se mettre à l'aise
ensuite vous pouvez faire quelques
étirements faut-il d'ailleurs s'étirait
va écouter pour ça il ya plusieurs
écoles l'ancienne école on a assisté
pendant des années à des gens qui
s'étirait comme des fous pendant de
longues minutes à froid sur tout ce qui
faisait que ça leur provoquer parfois de
vilaines blessures des microlésions dont
il avait du mal ensuite à se remettre
c'est pas le but recherché évidemment
donc aujourd'hui la nouvelle école
consiste à dire que les étirements c'est
bien mais avec parcimonie quelques
secondes on relâche quelques secondes on
relâche par exemple pourrait prendre
l'extrémité de votre jean votre pied et
puis vous étirez vous relâchez vous
étirez vous relâcher ou alors vous
pouvez faire des mouvements que l'on
qualifie de balistique c'est à dire que
vous lancez votre jambe en avant puis en
arrière de plus en plus haut en avant et
en arrière c'est l'étirement dure
quelques millièmes de seconde mais ça
permet à toute cette musculature de se
mettre efficacement en éveil
voilà pour ces conseil mettez la à
profit mon running
[Musique]